PRECEDED IT COME THIS
NOVEMBER.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION
IS SEAN DUFFY, A REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FROM WISCONSIN.
AND WITH ME HERE IN THE
STUDIO IS PHILIPPE REINES
ADVISOR TO HILLARY CLINTON
2016 CAMPAIGN.
GENTLEMEN, GREAT TO SEE BOTH
OF YOU TONIGHT.
LET'S START WITH YOU FELIPE,
THIS LAWSUIT, I READ ALL 64
PAGES.
I MEAN IT'S 64 PAGES.
AND IT'S GOOFY.
ARE THEY GOING TO SERVE LIKE
VLADIMIR PUTIN WITH PAPERS?
THIS TO ME LOOKS LIKE THEY
ARE NOT GETTING WHAT THEY
WANT WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION IS NOT
GOING ANYWHERE.
MAYBE SOMETHING WILL HAPPEN
WITH COHEN.
THEY HAVE TO DESPERATELY
KEEP THIS THING GOING.
BREATHING MORE AIR ON THE
FIRE UNTIL THE MID TERMS.
IS THIS THE REAL DEAL OR
WHAT.
>> WELL, I'M NOT A LAWYER
BUT I UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW
CONGRESSMAN DID YOU HAVEY.
BEAR WITH ME WHILE I MAKE A
POINT.
HE WAS ELECTED IN 2010.
>> Laura: YOU ALWAYS DO
LITTLE RESEARCH ON THE
GUESTS.
>> I WAS HOPING HE WOULD BE
HERE.
>> Laura: YOU PULL THAT
EVERY TIME.
YOU COME OUT WITH A TID BIT.
>> I WORK WITH SOMEBODY WHO
LIKES TO BE PREPARED.
HE WON DECENCY AND YOU WON
HANDILY YOUR LAST TWO.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I HOPE
YOU LOSE IN NOVEMBER BECAUSE
I'M A DEMOCRAT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO FLIP THE HOUSE.
I WANT TO YOU LOSE FAIR AND
SQUARE OR WIN FAIR AND
SQUARE.
I DON'T WANT ANYONE
MEDDLING.
I KNOW NO ONE LIKES TO ADMIT
THAT THE PROBLEM WE ARE IN
NOW IS THAT IT IS SUCH A
HILLARY CLINTON BLAMES
RUSSIA THING THAT NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT RUSSIANS OR
CHINESE OR NORTH KOREANS OR
AROUND WITH OUR ELECTION.
AND THE POINT TRYING TO MAKE
ABOUT THE COURT IS BECAUSE
IT'S A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS,
THERE ARE NO BILLS TO
PROTECT THE ELECTION.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE
LAWSUIT CAN'T BE FIRED.
>> Laura: GO AHEAD, SEAN.
>> IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
IT'S RICH THAT THE DNC IS
TRYING TO FILE A LAWSUIT
ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THE VERY DNC THAT HIRED AND
FUNDED A DOSSIER WITH
INFORMATION THAT CAME FROM
RUSSIAN INFORMANTS.
THEY ARE OF THE ONES THAT
COLLUDED WITH THE RUSSIANS.
BEYOND THAT I DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY DON'T NAME BARACK OBAMA
WHO DIDN'T DO ANYTHING IN
THE ELECTION OF '16 TO STOP
THE RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN
THE ELECTION OR JAMES COMEY
WHO CAME OUT AND DID PRESS
RELEASES ON HIS
INVESTIGATION.
BUT, FRANKLY I THINK THE DNC
SHOULD HAVE INCLUDED GARR GARMIN
AND GOOGLE MAPS BECAUSE
HILLARY CLINTON COULDN'T
FIND WISCONSIN ON THE MAP TO
CAMPAIGN.
TO COME AND MAKE UP EXCUSES
WHY THE DEMOCRATS LOST IS
PATHETIC.
THEY HAD A BAD MESSAGE AND
BAD CANDIDATE.
DONALD TRUMP UNDERSTOOD HE
HAD TO GO OUT AND WIN THE
ELECTORATE WITH A SET OF
IDEAS THEY BOUGHT INTO.
THAT'S WHY WE WON.
I AGREE WITH YOUR POINT.
I HOPE THE DEMOCRATS KEEP
TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA.
I HOPE THEY KEEP NANCY
PELOSI IN THE LEADERSHIP
POSITION BECAUSE WE'RE
FOCUSING ON IDEAS THAT GROW
THE ECONOMY, THAT MAKE
PEOPLE'S LISTLESZ BETTER AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
AND DEMOCRATS CAN'T GET
BEYOND WHY THEY LOST THE
LAST ELECTIONS AND RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
>> Laura: GLORIA WAS ON ESPN
TODAY.
THIS IS WHAT HE SHE'D ABOUT
THE LAWSUIT.
>> HONESTLY, IT'S JUST A WAY
TO RAISE MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IS RAISE MONEY OFF OF
IT ONE MORE WAY TO GET INTO
THE ACT HERE AND CONTINUE
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
ALL ALONG.
>> OKAY.